imagine waking up in the early hours of
the morning to see this
firefighters tackling flames and smoke
at a hostel in New Zealand's Capital
City details about the incident are
still emerging but City officials moved
quickly to help it's a strange situation
to be in as the mayor I've
I'm feeling a lot of pain and emotion
for those who have been lost
and
at this moment we just have to get
those who have made it out of the
building getting them feel safe the
loafers Lodge has 92 rooms and while
most guests have been accounted for a
number are still missing survivors
grateful to have made it out alive
it's scary you may been you know
first time I've been in the house fire
especially on the third floor because
you know you're thinking I'm going to
get done but you know I made it out
safely firefighters described a
confusing and chaotic scene when you're
woken from your sleep with alarms going
smoke
um people would have been pretty emotive
trying to escape for the crews that
would have been pretty horrific Flames
coming out of a building with people
inside is our worst nightmare
are underway as New Zealand faces the
aftermath of this terrible fire it will
be a thorough review of this as there is
in these sorts of situations there will
be an opportunity to test whether or not
you know this building was fully
compliant with all of the rules that it
needed to be compliant with as the facts
are established what is clear is that
the damage and the loss is devastating
summer Chowdhury Sky News